President Biden is not in this country
he's overseas in Japan for the G7 Summit
arrived early this morning D.C time late
afternoon there the city of Hiroshima
where he'll be tackling a wide range of
foreign policy issues but also as you
may recall cutting his international
trip short to work on a deal with
Republicans to raise the debt ceiling
Nicole Killian is on Capitol Hill for us
this morning really where the action is
Nicole good morning hey good morning to
you Tony speaker McCarthy is now
directly negotiating with the White
House he said both sides met last night
and will continue to meet until they
reach an agreement
as rain bounded the tarmac where
President Biden touched down to meet
with global leaders in Japan back home
his top aides conducted their own
diplomacy on the debt limit I'm
confident that we'll get the agreement
on the budget that America will not
default the president's team huddled
behind closed doors for hours Wednesday
with representatives for speaker Kevin
McCarthy who's also participating in the
talks the only question is whether we
have a buying default or not is the
president himself the bill is passed
House Republicans have been pushing a
bill they passed last month that would
raise the debt ceiling through March of
next year and slash 4.8 trillion dollars
in federal spending where are you
willing to compromise I'll show you when
we're done one sticking point whether to
impose stricter work requirements for
those on government assistance like food
stamps or Medicaid which the president
said he may not accept if that's one of
the things he's he's calling out No Deal
Democrats are working on a potential
backup plan if talks collapse including
a procedural move to force a vote on the
debt limit meanwhile a group of senators
circulated a letter urging the president
to exercise his authority under the 14th
Amendment the United States has to pay
its bills it's in the Constitution so
it's a fight worth having do you want
the louder click or the softer click the
uncertainty makes Annabel Bivins nervous
she runs a pet store in a donkey daycare
in Virginia and worries she may have to
cut back on staff if the economy takes
another hit cutting hours is definitely
going to be the first way that we go
if the U.S defaults experts warn people
may not receive Social Security benefits
service members may not get paid and it
could rattle Market which could impact
401ks and make it more expensive to
borrow money Nate
the financial ripple effect could be
devastating to some Nicole thank you